we have breaking news this morning in
the case of larry nassar the former team
doctor for usa gymnastics is serving an
effective life sentence for sexually
abusing hundreds of athletes now
survivors are demanding more than one
billion dollars in damages claiming the
fbi's failure to protect them was a
dereliction of duty they include
olympians simone biles ali raisman and
michaela moroney maggie nichols the
first to report nassar's abuse to the
bureau and nearly a hundred women who
were abused after the fbi was told nancy
chen has more
in a federal claim filed against the fbi
today victims of larry nassar accused
the agency of failing to protect them
between july of 2015 in september of
2016 by mishandling credible claims of
sexual assault that allowed nassar they
say to continue preying on girls the
survivors including team usa gymnastics
stars simone biles ali raisman michaela
moroney and maggie nichols say the fbi
declined to conduct interviews with
victims and failed to report nassar's
child abuse to the relevant state and
local authorities where nassar continued
to abuse victims more than 90 young
women were abused between july of 2015
and his arrest in november of the
following year john manley is one of the
attorneys representing nassar's
survivors
do you think that more young women and
girls would have been protected if the
fbi had acted sooner
well we know that he was seeing eight to
10 patients a day sometimes 15
and molesting them little girls
last year maroney nichols raisman and
biles all testified on capitol hill
about the fbi's inaction it was like
serving innocent children up to a
pedophile
on a silver platter fbi director
christopher wray that same day pulled no
punches on the bureau's response to the
case i'm especially sorry
that there were people at the fbi who
had their own chance to stop this
monster back in 2015 and failed a
department of justice inspector general
report released in july of last year
agreed with that sentiment finding that
agents went as far as to lie to the ig
to cover up their actions the agents
involved were either fired or retired
but the doj never prosecuted anyone so
you have not only the cover up the
hypocrisy but this double standard and
it smells like dirty cops trying to
protect dirty cops for cbs mornings i'm
ninci chin